au douzième fête le glossy comment la
noblesse et mais se distraire à
l'extérieur avec des joutes équestres
jusqu'à leur interdiction après la mort
tragique d'henri 2 lors d'un tournoi les
affrontements avaient duré des semaines
entières pour le plaisir des protégés du
royaume aujourd'hui en france une
poignée de passionnés reconstitue cette
histoire et sont même affiliée à la
fédération française d'équitation du
sport spectacle c'est un spectacle
historique qu'il faut mener avec les
mêmes armure les mêmes couverture les
mêmes celles qu'a l'époque puisque
c'était un sport à l'époque à l'époque
le jeune noble venez faire du tournoi
comme aujourd'hui un garçon va acheter
sa porsche voire trois porsche pour
faire le mans c'était le même principe
[Musique]
chaque année à la mi-août la foule se
presse pour assister à l'événement de
chevalerie quatre spectacles par jour
pendant un week-end des jeux d'adressé
des combats des costumes et des tenues
d'apparat l'armure qui pèse plus de 30
kilos a toujours autant de succès c'est
vraiment excellent ça fait du bien de
voir aujourd'hui en 2021 ce qu'on n'a
jamais pu voir cinq six siècles en
arrière c'est
magique surtout pour les enfants mais
nous aussi à ces super ya de l'animation
et des chevaux et des chevaliers se
battent
en une décennie grâce notamment à ce
tableau historique si séduisant pour le
public leurs rivaux a retrouvé la
notoriété qui lui convient et justifie
pleinement son classement au titre des
châteaux de la loire en fait on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on est
exactement dans
l'idée de ce que les gens peuvent se
faire d'un château en pleine campagne
avec un service de restauration un hôtel
mais aussi des nombreuses animations les
gens peuvent prendre le temps profiter
des jardins respirer les fleurs être en
contact avec histoire les visiteurs ont
jusqu'à dimanche soir pour se plonger
dans l'ère du moyen-âge chevaleresque
plus délicat